okay let's go to our next caller from
the 6:00 to 3:00 area code caller from
6:00 to 3:00 go right ahead I did
my name is Matthew from Arizona great
so I've seen coverage on Betsy DeVos
basically only talking about her yacht
I'm sure you saw that as well my
question is have you seen a report on
her company with a spectrum health their
servers connecting Trump Tower and
Russia alpha Bank yes I have seen that
but I you know I haven't seen any
coverage on it so um maybe I don't
haven't we known that for like eight
months or something I feel like that's a
story we did some time ago I think that
we covered it at the time and I don't
know I mean we can cover it again I just
don't has there been anything new about
that no actually I'm just like from from
them uh how do you say from the
mainstream media I haven't seen anything
from that but oh I mean isn't there
anything any problem or investigation
into her rights because you know for
corporate media to explain that story
they can't do it in 90 seconds so
they're basically not going to tell that
story like you need to explain the
connections between Trump Tower and
alpha Bank the Alpha bank executives how
that's connected in the back to Betsy
DeVos his brother Erik Prince formerly
of Blackwater who was negotiating a
back-channel in the safe shell you it's
like you can't that I'm not surprised at
all I barely watch corporate media but
of course corporate media is not talking
about that story it's just it's too it's
it's too complex I think that that's the
right word yeah I'm gonna require a
Rachel Maddow a block yes get through
the whole store Rachel Maddow would get
four and a half hours lay it out yeah
okay I think we lost them very good
thank you appreciate a call but it is a
very very important issue strange things
going on with the phones today